Here's the answer. What we need to do is have three parameters in addition to
the self object. So we have the name parameter already. We need owner and chef.
And now we're just going to initialize attributes to those values. And the names
happen to match here. There's no reason they need to. That's just for[INAUDIBLE]
and probably it's actually a better idea to make them not match sometimes I use
the convention of using p in front of the name to indicate that, that's the
parameter. So then we would have the p here for those names, distinguishing them
from the attribute names that are part of the object. As long as you pick names
that are clear, they can be whatever you want.[SOUND] Now when we initialize a
restaurant we need to pass in three values,[SOUND] and we can see that all those
attributes are defined in the object.